former republican congressman devin
nunes who is affiliated with donald
trump's social media platform truth
social appeared on fox news the other
day
and he
unleashed
a dizzying array of conspiracy theories
when asked about the documents seized
from donald trump's mar-a-lago home as a
result of the fbi search warrant and i
actually am not even sure what the total
number is that this is really something
the question is about the documents and
the search warrant from maria bartoromo
and devin nunes tries to blame obama
benghazi i mean it's just completely all
over the place
see if you can count the number of
completely unrelated conspiracy theories
that nunes mentions here and the sad
thing is
this is what the right is adopting as
their perspective on the search warrant
obama benghazi witch hunt robert mueller
fast and furious whatever
check this out try to count them up so
so devin nunes you came out with the
nunes memo in 2018 and exposed all of
them
is it the same documents that they want
to have under lock and key that they
wanted to get from trump's home
well look i don't think we know that
because i'm not sure they even got a
whole lot of documents anyway they
haven't even accounted for them but
maria i would only disagree with cash i
don't normally disagree with cash but i
think this actually goes back pre-russia
gate hoax i think this goes back to the
irs scandal where they targeted
conservatives now there's all that's
three okay
the current fbi search warrant is over
stuff that trump took home
in 2021 it has nothing to do with the
russia hoax or the russia probe number
two the russia probe was not a hoax
it actually found uh was it there were
34
indictments of individuals and three
more of companies or something like that
um and
the uh irs scandal where they targeted
conservatives wasn't really a thing it
actually turned out that they were more
or less equally
looking at organizations based on
liberal and conservative leading
keywords so we're already three cons
he's only been speaking for 10 seconds
and we're already three conspiracy
theories in it goes back to
fast and furious during the obama
administration where they ran guns and
tried to set people up remember in the
innocent americans ended up getting
killed now fast and furious was a
program
where federal agents allowed some guns
to be sold and brought
uh into mexico
so they could trace the weapons
and
you can argue it was a bad idea but it
wasn't started under obama um and it
also has nothing whatsoever to do with
what's happening with donald trump right
now it goes back to benghazi they got
away with that now they didn't get away
with anything with benghazi this is
conspiracy is this conspiracy theory
five or six so far
no one got away with benghazi it wasn't
something to get away with it was a
tragedy because people died hillary
clinton was investigated in a dozen
hearings she testified under oath for
more than eight hours something donald
trump has never done
and she was found not responsible but
again what does it have to do with this
search warrant nothing you have to
remember it was late 2015 or 16 that we
get to the plan where the clinton
campaign working with dirty cops at doj
and fbi and the media i must say where
they set up to spy on the trump campaign
and ultimately republicans and frame an
innocent man that then led that never
happened
i mean in 25 2016
hillary clinton did not work with dirty
cops and the media
to set up to spy on the trump campaign
it didn't happen this is the trump thing
they spied on my campaign i'm sure some
of you have heard trump say that they
spied on my campaign
no
what happened was
in 20 it's actually it's an it's a huge
indictment of the trump campaign what
actually happened what actually happened
is that the trump campaign in 2016
was regularly in contact
with so many people under surveillance
by the fbi
that in surveilling their targets
the fbi stumbled across conversations
with people in the trump campaign so
like i'm going to give you an example
right imagine that
joe schmoe
is under fbi surveillance don jr then
get out gets on the phone with joe
schmoe
so there's a recording of joe schmoe's
conversation with don jr don jr is
incidental to the entire thing it's joe
schmoe who's under surveillance and
because the trump campaign in 2015 2016
was in touch with so many people who
were of interest to law enforcement they
ended up coincidentally on some signals
intelligence it's it's an insane story
but as devin nunes tells it it's
completely untrue who what so that was
the russia hoax that then led to the
mueller witch hunt so okay and again the
mueller witch hunt
led to 34 indictments of people
three indictments of companies
recovered more money than it cost and
was unable to say that donald trump did
not commit obstruction that's the truth
of the so-called mueller hoax witch hunt
whatever it is he calls it
are we up to seven conspiracy theories
here or maybe eight this stuff is
intertwined and then you just fast
forward you know cash mentioned you know
the whitmer case and jan six and whether
or not federal agents were involved in
that
so you just stare and that's another
conspiracy theory were federal agents
involved in january 6th
there is no evidence
that federal agents were involved in
january 6. this is the inside job
conspiracy theory some people will just
generally cite it and say it was it was
an inside job it was actually some
people will say it was antifa or black
lives matter others will say it was the
fbi that actually did the trump riots
now
there is a guy named ray epps which many
on the right fixated on
a guy who was at
the
at the capitol the day before the riots
and i think the day of
and um
people have asserted without evidence
that ray epps is an fbi agent there's no
evidence of that and there's no evidence
that federal agents were involved in
january 6. i think that that's eight
conspiracy theories at least
and then ultimately this leads to what
this leads to something never done in
american history before you had a
president's home ransacked by the same
goons that were involved in all of this
and i would say that that you know a lot
of people have criticized you know the
and that is not a conspiracy theory but
it's just a very dumb topic talking
point that this has never been done to a
president in american history that's not
really anything endless things happen in
the world
and at some point they happen for the
first time
no president has done the things that
donald trump has done before and so it
shouldn't come as such a big shock that
the outcomes have also been different
this is absolutely nuts eight conspiracy
theories in about 90 seconds of devin
nunes speaking
and all sorts of other deranged and
nonsensical statements like this has
never happened before and therefore it's
bad and unfortunately
they just nod along on fox news
maria bartoromo and cash patel
this stuff spreads like wildfire we
already saw it in interviews done with
uh protesters outside mar-a-lago
repeating a lot of these same things
it's never been done before what about
benghazi what about obama gate which we
still haven't even figured out what it
is
it works and it's a circle they say it
because the followers believe it and
because the followers believe it they're
encouraged to continue saying these
things and then it's just a circle of
trash
rather than a circle of truth the circle
of truth is nowhere to be found